das ist der gong und das ist moritz wir
beide machen reportage gerade fertigt in
den endzügen für das wdr fernsehen heute
abend 20.45 also montag den 20 18 und am
21.8 am dienstag um 20 uhr auf
einsfestival und der kommt darin vor und
spricht unter anderem über let's play
und was ist für poker der edna bricht
aus
entwickelt hat bedeutet hat das gros
play oder diverse let's play mit diesem
game gemacht hat das und noch viel mehr
ist eine reportage für leute die noch
nicht so viel von games mit und gaming
mitbekommen haben damit die man so ein
bisschen den einblick darin kriegen also
viel spaß dabei
und wenn ihr das video seht nachdem
diese beiden tage waren 20 81 18
dann gucken wir das war links auf online
versionen hier in info text oder in
merken packen also bis dahin bleibt